by the way we're in the crest theater in
westwood where's this Gala is called a
Chris Westwood it's a beautiful theater
that I did in a premier from a short
film in 2010 and they were amazing to
give us this great place beautiful yeah
it has a nice like Art Deco yeah to it
and nice couches in the front and seats
in the back one very fortunate to use it
talking about your five hundred dollar
short film versions versus a
feature-length would you recommend that
most filmmakers take the time to write a
short before of the same movie that you
did with on the horizon and then turn it
into a feature or was that just sort of
a happy accident that happened it was a
nappy accident I think it's a good idea
when it's time for investor sometime you
can just if you don't have let's say a
big background of film that you did
before then it will suggest at least do
a great short film of maybe a scene or
concept wise something like whatever
like a there's a term about it but it's
like maybe a ten ten minute version how
they film something like that and then
showcase that to investors that's really
going to tell them just your style
directing style and then you can say
with if we have more money than we can
do this this this is but at least its
people work with visuals so at least if
you show them something that's really
really going to help a lot and then
after that you have to put a business
plan because they're all about numbers
but for the features in itself I guess
it didn't for me for example I do short
film when I have a concept that I want
to work with and like four people I'm
gonna do something soon that I think I
don't know but I'm kind of sure that's
gonna be about my next feature film so
again sometimes it's just always at the
exit and some time to try a new
technique and stuff like that but i will
recommend that if you're trying to get
investors and you don't have a lot of
work than yet to do a shortened version
at least two to help them visualize what
you're trying to do because it's easy to
just like it's gonna be amazing it's
gonna be great it's not please just show
that you can do something instead of
just talking i know you've said before
that you feel 25 minutes is probably way
too long for a short film
should be to the point around ten
minutes don't drag it out say what you
need to say right away even now I think
five minutes three minutes is I think
because people have like an attention
span of like a two-year-old like they
just watch something they close it right
away so when they're going to click on
it and it's like 15 minutes they're not
going to watch it so I think it's better
to do a three minute something that is
straight to the point and just really
knock them with three minutes instead of
boredom with 15 so but again it's the
depend of the audience when you work
with something for three minutes two
minutes you can have a wider audience
but if you were with something of 20
minutes then you're gonna have a
specific audience so of the 30 short
films that you've made what was there
ever a time when you're like you know
what this story can't be told in 10
minutes it's got to be longer and how
did you you know cut those precious
pages of the script I did and my two
longer my two longer short film they
were my the worst one so now that's why
I think the three four five minutes it's
where I think you can really do
something any wait for me that for my
experience I think that's where you can
really do something great because I and
now I don't know now I'm kind of used to
work on the feature film that I didn't
mind for four years so if I'm gonna
write something kind of long of 25 pages
I'm just gonna go to 90 you know what I
mean I'm just gonna stop at 25 I'm not a
big fan of writing so from it's kind of
hard to do that so I prefer to just if
I'm going to commit to something I want
to commit completely so I know if I'm
going to do a short time I want to stop
around five minutes so it's around 56
pages max and then if you're going to do
a feature from just really focused on
doing that why do you feel those two
films that were your longest where
you're worse just I don't know
acting-wise just on paper sometime it
looks great but then it was like in 2008
something like that so the more you do
the better yes so but just some time in
paper is great then the execution just
failed just acting why is the casting
location and the camera at the time we
didn't have liked like this in depth of
field or something like that it was a
you need to have an adapter to try to
fake it so the technology was not
pleasing as now so maybe now if I were
to do something longer it will look way
better and but I don't know for sure so
I still prefer five minutes just you
have a concept and it needs maybe for me
for example on my film it's always about
a moment for short rim for example it's
always a moment a moment in time that
I'm trying to explain in like 3-4
minutes instead of just like this is the
story of Mike who's doing did it at who
cares I just wanted like sit right go
into a world a world right away and get
out so
you